hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new
sony wh-1000xm4
this is an updated version to the m3
which was one of my favorite headphones
the past year the noise cancellation was
incredible lupus right here
industry leading noise cancellation that
i'm excited to hear
or i guess not hear the difference
let's unbox and we'll talk about some of
the features because these headphones
have a lot of features packed into them
you've seen nothing easy set up a one a
two
that's it two there's two steps one of
the things that i loved about the
previous version and i'm also glad
it is in this one as well is the rose
gold
accents beautiful this also is taking me
back
to last year when i first got this pair
it was at camera cam
camera camp was an event that my sister
and i did with sony and
we had the best time ever and
unfortunately we weren't able to do it
this year so now these headphones are
just reminding me of how much fun we had
at that event
look at this i like this because i have
all my headphones actually hung up
in my closet so this is nice i can just
add that right there
to the hook
oh yeah they do come in two colors the
other one is more of a silverish beige
color and these are the black version
oh my gosh we've also got some cables
3.5 millimeter jack
we've got this for airplanes where will
i use you again
i can't wait and a usbc cable to charge
so i like that there's not a lot of
buttons this does have two buttons right
here there's a custom and the power
button
the actual sides are touch sensitive so
you're able to control
the music and there's even a really cool
feature where if you put your
hand over your ear it'll then activate
the microphones around and you'll be
able to hear
the outside world my music is playing
okay hand over the ear and guess what i
can hear you tyler say something
i mean i knew i could hear you already
but it's a great test
okay now i'm gonna take my hand up
[Music]
one of the big differences though just
looking at this especially inside of the
left ear cup it has a proximity sensor
this is brand new to these headphones
and this will allow you
to take your headphones off and your
music or your tv show will pause so
it'll know when you have these on
and when you have them off there's a ton
more settings in the
accompanying app time to switch to
another device
one of the things that's updated in this
version is you can connect it to
multiple devices at the same time so if
you're on your phone or on your laptop
you'll be able to
switch between the two and you don't
have to go in and automatically connect
it to bluetooth each time
okay i'm listening to my music now i'm
going to hit play on this youtube video
[Music]
youtube video playing hey guys it's
justine and today we are checking i
can't hear you
so that's wh hi maddie nx4
adaptive sound control yeah i'll use
i'll use it
this actually uses gps to figure out
what your location is and where you are
and how
these should be adapting to it the 360
reality audio setup
this is awesome you actually scan your
ear well you take a picture of it and
then it sort of scans it for you
let's do it take a photo of your ears
for analysis analyze your ear shape
please bring the camera closer turn your
head slowly to the right
photo oh that's my ear
turn your head slowly to the left please
do not move the smartphone oh
my god my ears are i wouldn't say
beautiful they're kind of weird looking
but that's fine
analyzing my ears are my ears going to
get a grade 360 reality audio isn't
available everywhere because you do
have to optimize your music or your
videos or tv shows for it
we actually tested at ces it was the
sony
car it was like a concept car and it had
360 reality audio in it
and it was awesome it was such a crazy
immersive experience
so fun so while i listen to some music
let me tell you about some of the top
features of these headphones
so the first highlight for me not
counting the improved noise cancellation
is the multi-device connection this will
automatically switch from phone
to your computer back to my phone again
and then back to my computer when i'm
editing and then back to my phone
when i start listening to music so
that's been super helpful
these are rated for 30 hours of battery
life with noise cancellation and you
only need to charge these for 10 minutes
and that will give you five hours of
playback the ear pads have
added 10 percent more surface area to
give you more contact
and the head cushion and band curves
were also redesigned for more comfort
i actually used just sleep with my m3s
all the time when i was on flights they
were so comfortable and the noise
cancellation was so amazing
that i would sleep the entire way unless
somebody woke me up and
had snacks then i'm up the app on your
phone
integrates really well with these it
lets you customize a lot of different
features
my favorite is the personal noise
cancelling optimizer
it determines the atmospheric pressure
around you and on flights this would
make such a huge difference
the motion sensor is the biggest
addition to these over the m3
this allows for wear detect so when they
aren't being worn they will pause
whatever's playing
and eventually turn off to save battery
this now has five microphones for
improved voice quality for calls
and to assist with precise voice pickup
this is kind of cool because if you do
decide to turn this on
when you start speaking your voice will
activate the ambient sound so you can
hear everything that's happening around
you and when you're done
you just double tap the right side or
you can wait 30 seconds
the noise cancellation is on like i i
really can't hear anything except this
music
now i'm going to turn on speak to chat
so as soon as i turn to speak to chat on
you'll see what happens now i'm talking
oh my gosh it's stopped the ambient
sound turned on like i can hear
everything
so if you want to stop this you can
double tap
my music has resumed oh okay no it
hasn't because now i'm talking again
so the thing is is speak to chat turns
on the ambient sound
and off the noise cancellation so that
you can hear things happening around you
i forgot that i had this turned on
before and i was sitting at my computer
testing these out and i started singing
to the song that i had playing
and then my music stopped and then i
heard myself singing
and the song went away i said but what
so here's all of the gestures that you
can use for playback control double tap
to play
or pause swipe forward for next track
swipe backward for previous track swipe
forward and hold to fast forward
and then release when you want to start
playback you can do the same if you want
to reverse
just swipe backwards and hold to control
the volume you just have to swipe up
and swipe down i'll put a link in the
description if you guys want to check
out these headphones i'm so excited that
sony added a lot of really great
improvements to the m4s and i would say
that i would see or hear you guys later
but i'm gonna go play some video games
[Music]
bye
you